[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talked about what today we have
wax rapper singer songwriter producer
comedian and very close friend
I like the shoulder touch I like wax
rappers wax rappers thanks reference out
with the W you know it was like boat on
rice candies
wait that's not wax oh that's right
paper it's wrapped in wax in in the rice
paper
you take the wax paper off in the ether
and it amount to much explanation
whatever you just said is where I got
money higher you look exhausted
Nicky's favorite rapper is eminent oh no
you think about that as a rapper I mean
I mean it was great he's pretty bad yeah
I love him you know wax has been a very
pivotal person and a lot of our lives
like you just kind of bring a lot of
people together like I think we met
Casey through you yeah yeah and tiffin
Casey made each other through that's why
I see time so much yeah their work for
you they would have never got together
oh wow yeah you know they said music
brings people together Joe music does I
think that Casey and TIFF met at one of
my shows we did and it brought them
together somehow do you guys remember
what song was of wax was playing when
you guys well when we first spoke to
each other there was no there were no
songs playing it was right before the
show at the Troubadour and Casey was
prepping for it wasn't like a class up
Oh
moment of silence but in their mind I
was this magic pretty much ya know and
then that's up that's the first time we
talked cuz he was on the stage and I was
like Casey because I recognized him from
Facebook because he was directing his
music videos
and yeah yeah big thing no you know the
directors and the writers all the
behind-the-scenes people she was a huge
fan she even made Isaac know a lot of
waxes music that's true one of the
actually the very first youtube video I
ever posted it was Isaac singing one two
axes the one worried though that the
girls getting boned by like eight was
the one she used to be mine yeah yeah
that one was crazy
wait so you were a fan of wax and then
you would stock his facebook and then
you saw this this guy it was Casey
randomly and you were like who's that
guy and then you've recognized him on
the stage at a show yeah what that is
pretty crazy I don't think I could
recognize things like that girl you can
your memory is so good I don't know yes
you have an amazing memory no but yeah I
don't know I think it was just it was
only wax too like I didn't fangirl or
like really dive deep into any other
artists at all it's just I really
gravitated to his music a lot and and
then just Casey's work on his music was
just really inspiring to me I don't know
I really like fell in love with Casey
through his work that's tight how did
you even find out about wax cuz you know
back in those days YouTube is like it's
not really like a popular medium yeah I
actually found out through my ex so my
myspace music no no my my ex-boyfriend
oh because that my ex platform's of my
angry he hurt my face no so my boyfriend
had a friend that I heard about wax on
YouTube cuz you had that first video
what was it called - how I remember he's
so [ __ ] now but the one where you're
in the cart the freestyle one with a
bird [ __ ] one I like the bird show new
crackles yeah that one so new crack um
and then so he told my ex about you and
then he ended up getting one of your CDs
and then he played it in the car and I
was like ah this dude is dope cuz I
don't even listen to rap either like
it's so not any first rap where you want
to listen to it have been dope
that's what's crazy about what's crazy
about life is I think like yeah if it
wasn't for me tiffen case would not be
married but really if it wasn't for your
ex's friend watching a video on YouTube
very much or if it was are you uploading
that video but you can always go back
further you could go back to that guy's
parents and like the [ __ ] said but
you know I think you should ask for 10%
of what they own I should let you go
back to and I should garnish their wages
yeah that's right when you guys raise
two paychecks here can I just get 10%
Yeah right immediately I'll call Michael
and now tip in case they get a don't you
guys get like don't respond sir by like
Walmart Home Depot make it the most
sponsors out of all of us yeah like the
best ones - yeah all the family movies
tillage or no the the real ones things
that you could be proud of yeah I got
like some like offshoot like toothbrush
company that no one knows about it
[Laughter]
[Music]
smiley now that's always enjoy watching
i watch the ads thoroughly yeah I have
to like if I do ads like it's it takes
the soul out of me where I have to
pretend like I like it I got to either
troll it or just do it straight up no I
hate that [ __ ] so I either just go like
can I just read whatever you have for me
and then I'll just read it and it's like
ooh and then I don't have to [ __ ]
like hey guys this [ __ ] cop is so
amazing
you know like I want to pretty much like
hey I'm doing this for money everybody
buy this toothpaste it makes your teeth
white yeah or or like I just make it
into like a skit or something really
funny then I can enjoy what I'm doing
but then I don't have to like pedal
something that I don't necessarily know
that much you know right yeah it's not
because I don't use the product it's
like I just get it and immediately I
already have a deadline and it's like
you got to get it done I feel like Joe
cuz a lot of I don't like this is kind
of inside baseball or whatever but a lot
of youtubers you get like bombarded with
lots of emails from like spam companies
that like want you to promote some ship
from China and stuff I feel like Joe's
the one accepting all of the young man
like you know how everyone goes Joe and
[ __ ] always talk about $20 is $20
that is me like two 32-bit to you like
what is it I don't give a [ __ ] I'll make
half a million dollars or $50 all of it
is okay with me you know why cuz I'm not
I'm not my Brad isn't big enough
you know me like I don't think like you
know I'm not like LeBron you know like
I'm like oh [ __ ] I should only get pay
like 30 mil you know what nothing has to
be about like how big your brand is it's
just how clean it is
because advertisers like to go towards
the clean like safer friendlier [ __ ] oh
no no I know about that I think I'm not
too proud as what I'm saying you know
like I'll take everything I think it's
like I don't want to do it like you like
I'm the opposite we're like I don't want
to do it anyway so if if there's not a
good tag and I don't even want to do it
and I like I just I just say no they got
stupid [ __ ] I'm broke I need it I get
sponsored by a lot of alcohol companies
though it's less dope and I actually
enjoy all of those alcohol companies I
do not discriminate see that that's what
I'm against for a longest time I'm like
I will not but can promote alcohol [ __ ]
- well it's like a hundred thousand
dollars oh yeah let's do it straight it
huh a straight edge no it's cuz I don't
drink [ __ ]
have you been thermo have you been
sponsored by weak company I think you
would be perfect for Isaacs with the
ball Isaac can rub CBD oil on him for
all my junior high eggs soon McDonald's
will sell weed so that's so Tiffany and
Casey will be oh you're right make do
bees or whatever you know do you do you
work with like CBD or any wheat brand
deals or anything like that they have
one sponsor I was like sponsor bikes um
some vape company in my podcast and it
was like the only for a little while
like I don't
nobody's ever reached out to that's
really surprising my content has always
been kind of you know I don't know like
ours maybe we would be the perfect thing
we would be the perfect thing to be hit
up by CBD companies like all the time
but it was only recently that you could
be sponsored by weed like Becky when I
first started YouTube you'd be like yo
I'm Steve I'm a drug dealer where you
put my foot and you know put my number
on the bottom of your video like that's
crazy that kids being born right now
we'll never know what it was like with
weed being illegal I would have never
guessed I would have never guessed when
I was a kid that this was the direction
society was going I knew like it was so
like you had to hide in the woods and be
like I saw my boy get arrested because
he had a weed seed on the floor of his
car and now like kids would be like we
we that sees in it you know what's crazy
is the some of our parents lived in an
era where like a lot of drugs were legal
right seventies and [ __ ] and then they
went back to like it's all like our
generation where it's like no none of
that it's all illegal and now the new
generation is like what are you talking
about so I don't believe in loss because
like laws they're just a bunch of humans
that know do we want it to be this yeah
with that okay the color blue illegal
tomorrow and all of a sudden hate blue
and then cops are beating you up cuz
you're wearing you in the next day
now that's Mickey green and now you
can't wear green or whatever and there's
just laws that go back and forth so I
believe in morals
more of a morals type of person morals
change - that's roulette sure do and you
can have a bunch of models in email they
have different malls in there they have
a lot of Morales a guy could have sex
with another guy he goes I guess yeah
okay though mm-hmm just gotta get some
wise in there yeah what do you call that
if a guy has sex with another guy in
jail but it's not gay survival it's
closer Bible yeah he's called being on
the down-low oh yeah that looks like
yeah oh I say that all the time but I
didn't do that it has a double meaning
yeah so if you're if you're in jail for
ten years and you start having sex with
guys because that's all available as a
man you have to think to get an erection
you have to be it's a mental thing yeah
you know so are you exciting your eyes
and basically using a man's [ __ ] to
masturbate with the assumption that um
you've the Hat you've been getting [ __ ]
consistently now put yourself in that
mindset you haven't had sex for a year
all booty hole looks good well I thought
that part of it was this there was the
domination of it - oh is it I thought
I've never been depressed like
dominating another dude another being
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you do whatever I
say give me your lunch tomorrow rape you
against rape and then there's consensual
sex but they're both can exist in prison
right right I would think that the
consensual one is the one using his
penis yeah and the rape one is the one
using his [ __ ] but what if he's using
this [ __ ] but he's holding hands with
the guy behind me I think that's
consensual dude or there isn't one of
these like this or there's an agreement
like if if I agree to be your [ __ ] then
you protect me in the yard you know
that's that's a business yeah isn't that
like more Stockholm Syndrome oh it cuz
you're cuz you're like I'll give you my
ass to protect me in jail I don't know
what Stockholm Sweden I like when you
have like the when you get
you get kidnapped and then you just stop
there and you can't leave your thing
yeah and you fall in love with your
kidnapper no I think that's a business
it's a business deal that I think
they're doing it's extortion yeah well
if you think about it when you if you if
you masturbate you're thinking of a
woman and then after years and years
you're like what do women look like yeah
what what and then you see the guy and
they mean Regina feels like cuz aren't
[ __ ] like don't doesn't it feel like
way different it does it's tighter but
drier I heard
what'd you say I said it's tighter but
drier I heard I mean I don't think you
had to say I heard at the end of that I
think that science I can't put my penis
in an [ __ ] though I will never know
you know I I did and there's caca there
you don't want to be there I don't think
your dick in there to know that but hey
the porn star lying to me but there is a
school of thought from a bunch of guys
in jail who believe that if you're the
one doing penetration
you're not the gay one the guy getting
penetrated is the gay one so their
definition of gay is just kind of weird
does this laughing go you gay ass
[ __ ] is all [ __ ] them yeah
that's why they have the term men that
have sex with men
it's called straight men that have sex
with man that's real yes yes it's like
the bottom and then it's like okay well
I'm always on the top cause I'm gay wow
so they're trying to change the
Webster's definition they don't even
read a dictionary dude it's not coming
from a very well [ __ ] using the man's
back is like a coffee table to put a
porn stacey's hot I don't know but if
I'm talking about a brand deals like
Walmart and Home Depot exactly
oh damn so what else have you been up to
wax that it's been working on music
that's a new album coming out I got a
new album coming out when is it come out
me in September I'm not like on here to
promote it and why not you should you
should use our platform we have a lot of
viewers out a buyer [ __ ] you want to go
gold promote it here
it won't at least not platinum though
you can't go Plateau wait let Joe read
the copy for your album perhaps this
video is brought to you by [ __ ] waxes
new album was it called bro it's called
bad sound it's called the sound of sheet
mix and also sponsored by lambskin
condoms and yeah it's a it's a it's a
full LP 12-track I'm just making this
[ __ ] up it's dope it'll make you [ __ ]
think about the world in ways that
you've never done before and like
lambskin condoms they don't make you
really feel yeah yo that's good what's
the hashtag interruptive [ __ ] I think he
felt it like he imagined that laughs
he's like oh I feel it we were talking
about Santa well we're talking about gay
sex it'll probably feel the same yeah
hashtag lambskins wouldn't feel
different a man or woman's [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I do have a I do have a
bring the topic back to anal sex albums
I appreciate you apologizing for
interrupting you in a bit
oh yeah man the link is in the
description box below wait when is it
debuting mid-september mid-september I
think the 16th I probably was gonna come
out before that so anticipate that well
I've been putting out a song from I've
been this whole summer I've been putting
out a song or two from the album every
Friday to make it kind of like just last
longer yeah where can they get that at
your channel my website is wax calm calm
waa emotion I'm just curious cuz I want
to go see your music can you give a clip
can you give a clip can I give a click
like seeing oak sing like a little like
snippet like it but then cut yourself
off like you cut off
yeah you mean like right now or like
you're gonna cut to it well right now
there's like 17 saws when you know how
you never make me cry but that's not me
sing it as a girl singing tell much more
beautiful bossa nova one yeah yeah this
girl Christa Christa young good body cuz
if you jump in it always blame the
foundation no you weren't you were
[ __ ] you were jamming up by ourselves
cause we're the boss my shoulder yeah
athletes ops we should just have a like
band waxes here you guys all do like
what's the cold oh my god my brain
doesn't work Orchestra I'm session thank
you she's if you saw that she goes I
know this brain last time you were in
this office main it was a while ago I
only remember the last time I had a jam
session you were then you said that so
it's such a sad way man after you feels
very empty inside
when I first met Joe and Bart I think
the first couple times I hung out with
y'all we ever have a jam session yeah
yeah used to jam in the garage drums
guitars fun we have instruments here
that are dusty cos Norman touches him
well you can understand looks like that
guitars only got three strings there's a
ukulele somewhere no that's in the other
office oh yeah yeah there's a clarinet
here my back you know what touch any of
that [ __ ]
don't touch that [ __ ] for that real
[Music]
double style go ahead Jim yeah Julie
like that like that one I do why aren't
you in America's Got Talent
I know don't egg him on wax Tony come on
I should get on huh I'm a Dixieland Joe
I played Dixieland
I even have the mouth part in all it
broke I played it to [ __ ] you know
though one of our ammo oh I'm glad that
broke I need to get a new one I know
what other answer I got this I like that
one yeah this is G no it's not shoulders
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this becomes a playpen really quickly
[Music]
[Music]